okay sounds like Sir Charles Barkley
will be perfect fit in fake news CNN
South Dakota Governor Christie gnome is
with us Governor great to have you
thank you all right thanks for inviting
me let me
I I happen to be a fan of Jason Aldean's
talented gifted musician he really is
and so if you look at the summer of 2020
which he takes footage from we have 574
official riots we had dozens of dead
Americans we had billions of property
damage and we had thousands of injured
cops that were pelted with Rick uh
bricks rocks bottles Molotov cocktails
and other weapons uh so why saying in a
small town where where people stick
together this doesn't happen why is that
somehow a lynching song
it's not it's a lie it's a lie promoted
by those who want to attack people who
love America and that's what Jason is
singing about all he's singing about in
that song is upholding the law
respecting people loving our flag and
loving America we should all Embrace
that as people who get to wake up in
this country every single day and get to
be free so it really is an agenda to
destroy this country and it's sad to me
that country music has become a part of
that agenda I've always been a big fan
of country music it's changed the
industry's changed those two songwriters
that wrote that song are dear friends of
mine I've known them for years and this
song came out in May so it's been out
for a couple of months but they decided
to take out Jason Aldean with their
agenda this week and you know I I spoke
out on it just because I think people
are getting persecuted in this country
for their beliefs and sometimes they
need to know that we've got their back
they need to have some encouragement
that there's people out there that
support them and are grateful for them
that they still love our country I I
hope he takes you up on your offer and
performs for the great people of your
state I would like to even go and visit
myself that'd be a fun day
um but you you think about all the time
and attention given to one right because
they could politicize that Riot you know
for example we we have all these deaths
of innocent people many of the
minorities in Chicago New York City
every weekend we don't know their names
because it can't be politicized when it
can be politicized we'll learn the name
and and I'm looking at this particular
case and all of this happened in the
summer of 2020 why was there no
Committee in Washington where was Liz
Cheney investigating those riots
oh exactly that is the truth remember
how they were holding them up as uh
people that were trying to promote
Justice and that they were trying to
promote something as equaling the
leveling the playing field it was it was
insane if you will notice or remember
Sean none of those riots happened here
in South Dakota I had a very direct
order with my folks here on the ground
that the first water bottle gets thrown
and we are going to shut that down that
is no longer a peaceful protest but many
leaders in this country Let It Go way
too far people were hurt it was
devastating but it was used as a
political tool and it is still being
used today to scare people and they are
using fear to control people they've
done it now for several years and we've
seen it blatantly play out across this
country people like Jason people like
Neil and Kelly who wrote this song
they're not letting fear control them
well you know what those riots really
happen those two two thousand plus cops
were really injured billions of property
damage and businesses destroyed and over
two dozen Americans killed during those
summer riots uh Governor I appreciate
your courage thank you for coming on
tonight hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else